walk into a Starbucks and you're gonna
feel a pretty laid-back vibe and that's
exactly what Starbucks wants but that
casual experience is actually the result
of tons of tiny very well-thought-out
details
[Music]
you haven't even walked in yet but
already Starbucks is working on you
start with the door handle designers
like to call this the handshake between
the customer and the store and this door
handle didn't get here by accident if
already is providing a little bit of
advertising getting you thinking about
the coffee you're about to buy Starbucks
is all about flow getting people in and
out of their stores in the most
efficient way possible in this store
they need to get people to the back to
place their order but how do they do
that without hanging giant order here
signs well they use lighting and visual
cues notice that the merchandise and the
food is back there and it's lit more
brightly than the rest of the store so
that when you walk in without even
realizing you automatically move toward
the back as you're moving back Starbucks
already knows that two things are
happening to you first you're getting to
see all the different seating options in
the place so you can decide where you
want to sit down but you're also getting
some positive reinforcement before
you've even placed your order you're
seeing all these nice people enjoying
their delicious cups of Starbucks coffee
you see this on the strip of countertop
probably doesn't look like much but
actually it's all part of Starbucks plan
to maintain your connection to the
people who work here if this wasn't here
the first thing you'd encounter after
you've placed your order are these
really tall coffee machines which might
kind of push you back from the counter
but because this continues you're drawn
toward the counter and because
everything is below eye level you can
remain an eye contact with the people
making your coffee thanks a lot so
here's a question I just gave Starbucks
my money so why am I seeing more
advertising for coffee
well Starbucks is based on repeat
business advertising to me on my way out
of the store is to get me thinking about
the next time I come back
[Music]